Shipyard owner Lambros mitsui DS is
expecting his tax assessment any day now
and that could spell the end of his
company which goes back three
generations this time it's udi's will
have to pay his taxes for last year and
his projected taxes for this year too
he's not sure he can pull that off its
stop everything and we try to give the
company and will she mitsui DS troubles
began with the financial crisis his last
major commission is here in drydock
half-finished the yacht was supposed to
be made bigger and faster but his client
ran out of funds much like what happened
to Greece as a whole the ghost of mater
when I call him to start to pay which
disappeared that was back when the debt
crisis hit since then athens has been
raising taxes for mitsui DS that's meant
a steady decline in orders the latest
twist a new luxury tax on small boats
like this one payable retro actively to
2014 if it wouldn't boat it's without
looks li test but the problem is when
you have a old wooden boat and covered
with fiberglass half after you transfer
again to look so the test that's created
the absurd situation that an opulent 50
meter wooden yacht made in Greece is not
subject to the luxury tax but this old
boat is unless the client figures out a
way to avoid the tax for example by
getting a fishery license
tax laws are very complicated and for
that reason people take advantage of
these changes every time they're changes
they try to see what are the loopholes
so they can if you if you if you want
they can utilize the system in to their
other advantage one of the shipyards few
remaining customers is bent guzik he
drives a car with more than 2.5 liters
displacement it's also been hit with a
special retroactive tax that legal
uncertainty is typical of the Greek tax
system it's never know how much tax they
are if I just that it'll be more than
they were told by me of it as this way
exactly gute SEC was able to avoid the
retroactive assessment by registering
his pickup as a company car which is
exempt from the special tax originally
from Germany van Goosen our ins a
restaurant near Thessaloniki that's also
been hit by new taxes since July he's
had to pay an additional ten percent
value added tax to the government it's a
hefty sum but goot sec can't raises
prices if he did he'd lose customers
we're scrimping and saving and cutting
star I have no choice even though it
makes things worse here in the long run
against them to go to nobody professor
it makes things worse because people who
lose their jobs no longer pay income
taxes so the state ends up losing money
in the end other restaurant owners take
a different tack they tried to evade
taxes entirely visit I haven't gotten to
the point where i fiddle my taxes that's
too risky but I understand the impulse
has gone snelson been guzik also owes a
new annual tax on his motor boat it's
more than 40 years old and it isn't
worth much anymore but that doesn't
matter as far as the tax is concerned as
he kept indoors and get off you I paid
my taxes for years in Germany and it
could be baffling there too but nothing
like this other ship owners have found a
loophole instead of leaving their yachts
in the water when they're not in use
they have them dry docked
then they don't owe the special tax that
also has a side effect though now most
of the state-owned harbors are losing
out on docking fees this state of
affairs is why many experts say it would
be better to overhaul the Greek tax
system from the ground up well I was ok
man story for him if we don't get a tax
and finance reform man gibster i think
it's all over for lauren globby that's
the most important thing right now
victus they punked a moment yeah
shipyard owner Lambros mitsui disagrees
if instead of finding loopholes everyone
pays the tax they owe the state's
coffers will fill up again then the
government can stop passing taxes that
threaten the livelihood of honest
taxpayers
you